That morning, we loaded into the vehicle, and I get tapped on the shoulder.
And I got told that I need to bounce up to the next vehicle.
And I said, "Catch you guys on the flip side."
And that was the last thing I ever said to 'em.
Next thing I know, I just hear the loudest explosion.
And I see that's my squad's vehicle that got hit.
The bomb flipped it upside down and ripped it completely in half.
And everything inside of it was just parts.
I am most proud of not blowing my head off by now.
It's just a whole lot easier if you're dead.
But that shouldn't be your tribute to your dead friends.
When they are looking down on you,...
...they don't want you to be living in the moment that killed them.
You made it.
You got home.
You should honor their memory by living the life that they didn't get to live.